Okay, welcome to theory and practice for ICV effects.
So before the advent of ICV effects, the workflow for most visual effect centric films
followed a fairly classical approach to producing the final image.
A distinct production phases were followed that included development, pre-production,
production, post-production, and distribution.
The classical workflow placed the production emphasis on two primary phases, those being
production and post-production.
Filmmakers and producers emphasized the adage of, well, let's just fix it in post.
This helped to address various animation and visual effects issues and problems and work
while also addressing various problems that may have been encountered on stage.
So anything that needed to be modified in principle photography, they fixed it in
post-production.
Now, while pre-visualization during pre-production had its benefit in helping various producers
and directors be able to visualize what was needed to be shot during production, it was
a slower process.
It was highly team-based, key-framed, animated, and using traditional computer graphics.
No real-time capabilities.
So everything needed to be playblasted or rendered and composited.
And basically, this whole process, especially with computer graphics, had a tendency to
bifurcate or split the whole creative process.
The director didn't really have the opportunity very well to see what was going on in these
various post-production phases.
Shots could potentially take days or weeks in order to see something out of it.
And even pre-visualization, though it was faster, it was not a very good quality.
And it was rather low resolution and, at best, provided at least some basic information.
If we look at what the ICV effects production workflow looks like for live action, it's
a little bit different.
So there's still the whole process of development where you have storyboards and scripts and
you're basically trying to come up with your basic idea.
But when moved into pre-production, instead of just simply going into a previs phase and
then into an eventual production phase where you're shooting on stage, the pre-production
element in ICV effects is a little more involved.
You do still have an art department, but the art department is supplemented with a
VAD or a virtual art department.
And this virtual art department basically spends its time perfecting a lot of the designs
and 3D graphics that are being generated by the art department in order for it to be
used in a live action and real-time environment.
So you get this cycle of the art department working with the VAD, who is also then talking
to the previs team, and we also have the visual effects team that's a part of the
pre-production process now.
So it's not that they weren't involved previously.
It's just now in ICV effects, they become an essential factor with these other three
elements in order to prepare content to go onto the actual stage.
So when we move onto the stage in production itself and we have an LED volume, this is
where things are actually being shot and it's being shot in camera in combination
with all of your foreground, mid-ground, and background elements, and it's all being done
in real-time.
That's why we call it in-camera visual effects.
All of these shots then that are shot and captured are sent over to editorial, where
editorial continues the process of putting it into a sequence, and then it is then
delivered to the post-production facility where VFX can be added and the whole
post-production process can do what its actual job is, and that is to sweeten the
final image so that it looks better and it doesn't have to worry about making story
corrections.
And this was the big weakness of the prior earlier model.
A lot of producers and directors would have to try and fix a lot of their issues and
problems in post-production, causing a number of various issues, everything ranging from
having to potentially do a number of reshoots through a number of financial factors and
cost inflation, just it creates issues.
And then ultimately the film is completed and, of course, heads out through distribution.
If we look at it from another perspective, this is just another graph that kind of
describes the same process.
But let's just look at it for a second.
You have the whole idea creation and it heads into this whole vortex of creative
elements. You have the art department, you have the VFX department, the previs
department, and the virtual art department.
They're generating all of this content that is going to be moved over into Unreal
Engine and you create assets that can be utilized throughout the rest of the entire
pipeline. This is critical.
Once these assets are available and ready within Unreal Engine, they can inform
things like your stunt vis, more on your previs and any kind of technical vis that
you need to construct to figure out specific issues and problems.
Finally, when it moves into principal photography, you have all these different
elements working in concert that are being fed by these assets that are being
developed. So whether you're shooting something on green screen or you're shooting
it live action, the virtual art department, all of it works together within principal
photography to produce a final image that can go out to editorial into post and
finally get your final edit.
Now, we noticed that there are a number of key departments that we're familiar with in
classical film production.
You have those that are above the line and those that are below the line.
Above the line, you know, director, producer, executive producer, cast and
casting director, classic.
But below the line, you have a number of different departments and there are some
distinct departments that are very much affected by the ICV effects process.
Let's take a look at them.
They are production, art, camera and VFX.
Of all the departments that are impacted by ICV effects, it's these four that are
probably impacted the most.
ICV effects also has a tendency to require the use of various sub departments.
Now, these can be sub departments that can be provided by third party vendors or they
may be actually, you know, some ICV effects specific departments within the company
that's providing your LED wall.
But if we look at them, we've already identified what the VAD is.
This is the virtual art department, handles asset ingestion, optimization and
environment creation.
But then you have a need for additional sub departments like animation.
You might need to have some specific artists on board to create various
animated elements for anything that you might need on stage.
So having a few animators on hand is important.
You have CG lighting.
That is a factor.
So these individuals will help you with your light planning for the LED volume, tone
and per shot lighting during principal photography and various post lighting.
So, you know, when you're dealing with something like an LED wall, you're not only
utilizing the lights that you have practically on stage, but also the light
that's coming off of the LED wall itself.
You need some mocap specialists for sure.
This is basically to help you handle performance capture, including face and
fingers, if you need that for any kind of animated element, along with handling
the tracking of the camera itself.
That's also handled through motion capture.
There is the need for camera specialists.
This is basically to help you with location scouting, more previous and
layout camera consulting and, you know, setting up your environments and worlds.
So these cameras will help you figure out what are the best angles to
capture this information.
And if necessary, you can work with your artists to potentially move various
elements in the digital world as a form of location scouting and modification.
Finally, you're probably going to need some sort of editorial team that's going
to be available to assemble rough cuts of all of this information throughout
the entire process.
All right.
Now for roles and responsibilities, there are several.
We have a number of different roles that we'll identify.
Basically, you are pretty much familiar with the director.
He's the guy who supplies the creative vision and the direction for the film.
But you also have other big major key players, like the virtual production
supervisor and his team of artists.
So basically the virtual production supervisor is going to be taken care of
all those things that involve the wall and the volume.
He and his artists, or she and his artists, they're kind of similar to people
who are skilled in the practical world around camera, those elements within
some things with cinematography, but it's all from the virtual side of the
house.
Next, you need to have a virtual production colorist.
This is basically to ensure that the LED color science is accurate.
This is extremely critical because what you're shooting through camera and what
you're displaying on the wall, you need to make sure that all of your color
science is in alignment.
Otherwise you might not have a very accurate color matching.
You have a stage manager.
This is the person that is basically handling all stage operations and what's
happening within the volume.
You have your VAD supervisor and all of the artists within the virtual art
department.
They're handling the design and the construction of all the various virtual
assets that are going to be placed up on the wall itself.
You have the MoCap supervisor and various operators.
These are the folks that are basically handling all the tracking and performance
management of anything that's being captured.
You have pipeline developers and engineers.
Now this is an unusual set of people and roles that you don't commonly find in
traditional production.
By having engineers and pipeline developers available, they can customize the Unreal
engine and add specific code or data that you might want to integrate.
And they're a great benefit to have around.
And then finally, of course, your animation FX, TD, and rigging personnel.
Any of these folks are basically going to be helping with the animation
process and they're also critical.
Next, I'd like to get into the various benefits of virtual production as a whole.
Like I said, virtual production is this umbrella term.
So it is something that we should think about in that sense.
Number one, there's the whole idea of like a unified asset creation pipeline.
And when we think about that, I mentioned earlier that when working in
Unreal engine, the whole goal is basically being able to create assets
early in pre-production that can be utilized during production and pushed
into post.
When that happens, you have a possibility of saving funds and saving time with not
needing to recreate the wheel or create new assets for new phases of the
production process.
Next, it's a programmable real-time production tool set.
I mentioned this earlier, the ability to alter or modify things in the code
of Unreal engine is really important and they can help you create custom
tools that you wouldn't normally find on the day.
Next, remote and multi-user capabilities.
This is a unique prospect here in that you can have individuals assisting and
contributing to the shooting process on stage who may not actually be located at
the stage itself.
Multi-user capability can allow for people to remote into this process, be able
to potentially provide feedback and or provide other types of graphics and
performance via motion capture or anything really.
But the whole multi-user capabilities within engine not only extends out to the
people outside of the stage, but also the number of different stations and
computers that are set up on the stage so that they can be all
interconnected and talking to one another, sharing those graphics and 3D
assets amongst themselves.
There's the aspect of allowing for real-time physics and simulations.
So again, if you want to have a potential animation that includes physics or, you
know, various simulations like cloth simulations or wind or various
environmental effects, that's something that can be done as well.
There's a reduced requirement on the rendering process for all this.
We'll get into the hardware specifically about what's needed to render in real
time, but instead of having to have a large render farm in order to see some
of this, this is going to all be rendered in real time.
And you have that interaction.
Real-time camera tracking, we mentioned this about the mocap personnel, but you
know, the cameras is tracked a hundred percent of the time.
So wherever the camera moves in real life, you'll see it update on the stage.
And finally, the whole data management aspect of all of this is tracked
through various source control applications with inside of the
engine, combining it with other third-party tool sets like Perforce,
which can keep track of all of your data.
Now getting a little more specific, there are some specific benefits to ICV effects.
Now this is again, not virtual production as a whole, but ICV effects specifically.
Number one in camera finals, this is huge.
You know, the ability to basically be able to shoot something through the
camera and have all of your elements in stage and get a final output or
a final shot, that's pretty important.
There's the whole aspect of proper reflections and lighting.
Big thing for being on an LED volume.
If you have all these LEDs behind you, delivering you some type of environment,
anything that's reflective inside of the volume, like perhaps a person's
glasses or anything like a car or some sort of glass, this can pick up these
reflections that are on the LEDs and give you an even greater sense of
realism that you wouldn't be able to do, you know, using prior techniques.
You would have to probably comp, you know, reflections into glass or
something like that, using a more traditional approach.
The LED volume can support dynamic animated backgrounds.
So if you've got some animation in the background, perhaps flying birds or,
you know, the process of smoke or, you know, swaying trees, all of that
can be animated and seen in the volume and captured live in camera.
There's better coordination with the VFX team.
When I showed you the workflow and pipeline, we have the VFX team now
keenly interested in this process.
So there, they will be more readily available in order to discuss these
options about how to make this whole process work smoothly.
There's rapid lighting and changeovers.
This is a big advantage of using the wall as well.
You can simply change out your environment and have a completely different
lighting setup at any point in time.
There's the flexibility to improvise on set.
You can move your set pieces around along with moving your digital set
pieces around to get a completely different composition.
Reduction on practical sets.
Again, self-explanatory.
If a lot of the background sets can be constructed digitally, there'll
be no need to actually try to construct that practically.
So it's a big benefit there.
There's the continuity of vision through post, meaning anything that you have
generated for this LED wall can be utilized in post-production as well
as part of the assets that are used.
So things that are rendered for the wall can also be used
as elements in final post.
All of this is all captured and maintained digitally.
So, Hey, if you need to do a pickup or a reshoot of some particular shot,
you can just bring that environment back up on the wall and you're back
in business in fairly short order, as opposed to having to go back on location,
potentially setting up new content in order to capture those shots.
Plus there's the whole issue of time and day.
When we're working on a wall, you can stay at golden hour
for however long you need.
There's a whole aspect of rich mid-tones and color values.
The wall just gives a really nice diffusion of light.
It's really quite beautiful, but that also can be a limitation,
which we'll get into in a moment.
There's the whole aspect of visual parallax.
As you move the camera, you get 3D parallax on the screen behind our actors.
And, you know, there's also the possibility of shooting all types
of different camera angles.
And I mentioned the whole aspect of diffused lighting.
All right, let's talk about some of the limitations of ICD effects,
because as good as the volume is, it can't handle doing everything.
So first on the list, we have transitions from the practical
to virtual world can be problematic.
What do I mean by this?
Well, you only have so much space within the volume.
You've got, you know, it could be anywhere from 10 feet
to maybe 30 or 40 feet, whatever it may be.
If you want to move objects from the practical world into the background,
this can be something that has to be thought about
with a certain amount of care.
Or if you're having digital elements somehow move on to the practical stage,
you're going to have to find a way to transition this to be more seamless.
And that can be problematic.
Next, we have mutual assets
usually are required for both virtual and practical sets.
Now, this is quite important.
Normally, when we talk about items that are on the stage,
you have items that you come to the stage with.
Maybe these are practical set pieces that you've built
or maybe it's digital assets that you have in CG.
You need to be able to have a certain amount of well,
you have to have exact parity between these two elements.
So if you started off and you have a CG element
that needs to be seen in the practical world,
you're going to have to build that practical chair or set piece or table.
Or if you've come to the stage with something practically
and you need to see it in the background,
you're also going to then have to build that in CG
in order for it to be seen in the ICD effects volume.
Next, there's the whole aspect of animated lighting in the virtual world
can be difficult to match practically. Very true.
Though this is getting a lot better,
we want to make sure that the color science is always accurate.
And this leads to issues about the LED black point,
various color science issues, practical light contamination.
And that can be a big headache for a lot of people, especially
if you have lights that are shining more direct light into the stage.
There's the chance that you might get spill onto the LED panels themselves,
which can potentially desaturate a lot of the images
on the panels that you're seeing.
It can be potentially detected through the camera when you're shooting.
This light contamination can be, like I said, very problematic.
Next, there's the issue of hard shadows and mimicking daylight.
This can be very difficult as well.
Very hard shadows is not something that comes easy on an LED volume.
The LED lights themselves, they produce a really beautiful diffuse light,
but they don't do much for actually producing hard shadows.
So in order to do that, you're going to have to introduce,
you know, these stronger practical lights that can be shined in on stage
in order to cast these hard shadows.
And that's where you have to be careful.
Next, reflective surfaces in the virtual world.
This can be an issue.
So, you know, you don't want to include anything in your virtual world
that might be a mirror or, you know, highly reflective
so that when an actor walks past that in the virtual world,
you're not going to be able to see the reflection of that actor
in that mirror or on that chrome surface or something like that.
So just keep that in mind.
There are some limitations on the frame rate.
Right now, for most stages that are out there now,
they probably have a maximum frame rate of 48 frames per second.
Most things are typically shot in 24 frames per second.
There are some that can do it in 48 frames per second.
But if you're wanting to shoot really high speed slow-mo,
you know, something like 120 frames or 240 frames per second,
that's something that is coming, but isn't quite available yet.
Next, this whole process, though it is rendered in real time
and on a number of great graphics cards,
it still requires a lot of compute resources.
You are going to need a machine room to house a lot of the computers
that are doing a lot of the work,
because it's not just the machine that's rendering Unreal Engine.
There are a whole series of additional pieces of equipment.
And this, of course, requires a lot of resources
to maintain power, HVAC, and so forth.
Next, the FX elements, these can be difficult to integrate too.
And these are the effects elements
that you might want to put into Unreal Engine,
like explosions in the background,
or some sort of particle system or lighting system.
You're going to have to potentially deal with that
in your live action element as well.
So how do those lights interact?
How do you make everything work?